young justin dunn
getting his fifth start of the year in
his last outing six days ago he took a
wicked line drive off his right side
stayed in to finish the first inning had
trouble in the second so he lasted only
two against the dodgers the two two
caught on and missed heater at the knees
first strike down for justin dunn
swing and a miss by santana for strike
three a couple of strikeouts back to
back for justin dunn and he takes care
of the rangers the mariners coming up
here in the bottom of the first inning
to take a look at veteran left-hander
mike miner now two outs for kyle lewis a
seven-game hit streak mike he was on
base five times last night he has just
been incredible lately
out to left
this is drifting back and this is gone
it's another home run
the seventh for kyle lewis you cannot
stop number one nice way to extend now
an eight game in history
two two pitch swing and a miss miner got
him on a breaking ball and the sides
retired in the second baseman roughneck
odor has aside from nola the wind up and
the 2-2 swinging a foul tip into the
glove of nola for strike three and
already that is strikeout number three
for justin dunn coming after rugnetto
door and the 3-2 pitch swing and a foul
tip into the glove of nola for strike
three down goes kinder philippa it is
strikeout number four already for justin
dunn he retires the first six texas
rangers in a row mariners have the only
run so far as we go to the bottom of the
second austin nola leads it out for the
mariners this is corked out to left
field this is on its way and gone
another mariners home run number four
for austin nola and it gives the
mariners a two-nothing lead just start
for dunn retiring the first six men that
he's faced swung on and popped to right
long run
can hear a bishop calling off shed long
he makes the play
pitch swung on bounce down to third
lopes in his first start at third base
in the major leagues throws across in
time and there's two down there's the o2
pitch
and swing and a miss struck him out
nine up nine down five strikeouts justin
dunn two outs of mana board for joey
gallo representing the tying run pitch
on the way swing and it's popped up out
near the bag at second shallow center
field going out to shortstop crawford jp
is there now adjust to his left reaches
up he's got it and that'll end the
ending and dunn continues to take care
of the texas rangers inning after any
done has been fantastic so far and
here's the pitch that is lying down the
left field line hooking fair ball
two hops to the wall connor falefa
cruising into second with a double there
goes the no hitter
swing and a miss by mathis for strike
three and that is strikeout number six
for dunn
holy smokes what an afternoon for the
kid out of freeport new york
so one on it two outs and that'll bring
up left fielder sam hagerty
high fly ball this has a lot of carry
back back to the wall and gone home run
sam hagerty is first in the show
four nothing mariners lead on a
milestone moment for sam hagerty first
two home runs came off sliders this one
off a fastball and lewis swings and it's
a high drive to deep left center field
that one's way back and solac with a
back to the infield catch
nick solak on the warning track to rob
kyle lewis who is in disbelief yaddio
rivera number nine hitting shortstop to
begin the sixth inning as justin dunn
pushes off comes home and there's a
bouncing ball left side off the glove of
the third baseman lopes
and reaching on an error is yadiel
rivera that ball kicked off the heel of
lopes mitt one two pitch from dunn
line drive center field going back is
lewis he makes the catch running to his
left
runner at second tags rivera he goes to
third there's two down here in the texas
six here's the one-two pitch to santana
done deals good swung on hit down first
baseline backhanded easily by evan white
again fun to watch him play first
nothing across four the rangers in the
sixth anthony misevich takes over for
the mariners first pits swung on hit to
left field haggerty went back a couple
now running in he's got good speed he's
coming on coming on sliding catch did he
make it yes he did
sam hagerty big contributions today for
the mariners wow
rangers are trailing four nothing in the
eighth inning and here is uh mathis
here's the three one math is the swing
and there's a well hit ball deep left
center field that one's way back and
that ball is history jeff mathis
his first home run of the year and the
rangers are on the board it is four to
one williams looking for save number six
with a three run lead top of the ninth
inning a save situation
check swing and he goes two outs
now last hope for the rangers ruling the
no door fly ball into right field braden
bishop is there waiting for it and
waiting and he makes the catch and the
ball game is over the mariners won it
four to one and they sweep aside the
texas rangers here in seattle